[Music]
evacuate the island I saw Jurassic Park
and I was 16 years old taught me a
lesson about what great movies can do
you know it doesn't have to be for
children it can be something that makes
everyone in the audience children for
those two hours I wanted to tell a great
story and I wanted something that was
going to be able to entertain children
to me it wasn't so much about the movie
it was more about our culture in general
and like this desire for constant
upgrades and you know entertain us more
and we're rid of a blasé attitude about
the scientific technological and also
natural wonders around us because we
have seen everything now we have the
Internet a little bit about you know the
corporatization of science and the
danger of bringing that need for money
and profit into a scientific process and
then it's also I think on a larger scale
and hopefully this is more for the
children who watch it it is about our
relationship with the other living
things on this planet and the planet
itself
Lyde in the movie that Irfan Khan says
dinosaurs are remind us how very small
we are and how new and that's one of the
reasons why I'm fascinated by them is
that in the same way that when you look
up at the stars and you are you field
Worf then you feel very small and you
recognize how how completely microscopic
your personal issues are and even this
planet is in general I think dinosaurs
do the same thing in the context of our
theme you recognize that you know we are
only the dominant alpha species on this
planet because we are here right now and
if we were here 65 million years ago
we probably wouldn't even be here we
would disappear very quickly
I think you know the characters are are
presented in a little bit more of a
great classical point-to-point
storytelling in the way that it's all
designed it's very simple and efficient
and clean I'm very proud of that and
what it does do that I that I really
love if I could name one thing is it
allows the dinosaurs to become
characters and I really embrace the fact
that the t-rex in the last movie
ultimately by the end you know she
starts off as a villain and then she
saves everybody she becomes a hero and I
thought that we could take that another
step forward and so there are several
dinosaurs in this movie that by the time
you get to the end you kind of know them
you don't just know their mythology but
you know a little bit about their
personalities so when they fight it's a
little bit more it's a little more
loaded there's there's their stakes
there that a little more emotional and
when it all goes down it's not just a
bunch of computers punching each other
it feels like you know living things
that you care about and you want to know
who wins and you know that especially
for kids that kind of stand up and Cheer
moment which is difficult to manufacture
you have to you have to earn it and I
think we have it in this movie and I
know I've seen audiences react to it and
and that that moment where you just get
this you know people people having the
time of their lives that makes me it
makes me very happy
you